- You do this thing where you
start typing and then stop.
(laid-back music)
- You strike me as the type of
person who never texts first
and that's just not gonna work for me.
- You always text first.
It's exhausting.
(laughs)
- You wake up how early?
- Yeah, I love sleeping
in way too much for that.
- I took a glance at your Netflix account.
Unfortunately, we don't
like any of the same shows.
- "The Princess Bride" is overrated?
Oh, so you're some kind of a monster.
- I'm not saying I don't want to date you
because you used the
wrong "your" in a text,
but that is definitely
what's happening here.
- A grammar Nazi, how charming.
- The amount of meat
you eat makes me worried
you're going to die before me.
- A vegan?
I don't know if I'm ready
to be that open-minded.
- We have a lot of mutual
friends on Facebook.
This strikes me as a high-risk situation.
- Oh my god, your mom
just Facebook friended me way too soon.
- Wow, you post a lot of
political articles on Facebook.
I don't know how I feel about that.
- The number of hours you spend
on your phone is terrifying.
- It horrifies me that you
don't know what Instagram is.
- You literally say the
word "literally" a lot.
- Oh, you have a selfie stick.
That just happened.
- You Googled me?
Ah, that is so creepy.
- A music snob?
That's fine 'cause I'll always love
Britney Spears more than you.
- You know this ain't ever gonna work,
but we can still make out.